sie sind auf der jagd und sie werden
immer mehr säubern
[Musik]
archäologen schlagen alarm
marion brückner ist aus grabungsleiterin
auf einem römischen gräberfeld 2000
jahre alt aus angst vor illegalen sonden
gelang haben sie und ihr team wenn
möglich nur noch unter geheimhaltung
wenn dann mit dem 105 fieber durchgeht
und die dann einfach immer weiter runter
gramm ist möglicherweise das herzstück
eines diskutierend ist oder sonst einer
aussage erlaubt ist dann weg und damit
für die wissenschaftler für immer
verloren
der schaden durch illegale sondengänger
ist schwer zu beziffern dürfte aber laut
polizei in die millionen gehen die
schatzsuche mit speziellen sondern ist
zum volkssport geworden
viele suchen hier in camouflage mit
westen technischen gerät das große
abenteuer und den größten fund
dann geht ja mit einer gewissen
vorstellung in dieses hinein und dann
hat man irgendwann dieses signal auf
einem gebiet vielleicht was wirklich
interessant ist und man glaubt das ist
es eben
jedes jahr veranstaltet die szene
schatzsucher meisterschaften in einer
großen rallye werden metall und
goldmünzen vergraben wer die meisten und
teuersten findet wird deutscher meister
erste münze ein hauptgrund eine
goldmünze damit können sie bei konkreter
meldung
alles nur ein spiel für erwachsene für
die archäologen marion brückler nicht
bei den meisterschaften will sie mit den
sonden gängern ins gespräch kommen und
darüber aufklären welche zerstörung von
den schatzsuchern ausgehen kann
meine schlimmste erfahrung der hat mir
gräberfeld untersucht und da ist dann
nachts jemand mit einem dreizack
durchgegangen und hat alles rausgeholt
was zu kommen war man konnte sich spuren
von dem dreizack noch sehen
und da geht natürlich so einiges kaputt
verbündeter im kampf gegen derartige
raubgräber ist ihr kollege peter henrich
aus koblenz
auch er hat mit immer mehr sonden
gegnern zu tun
er erklärt was sie brauchen um eine
genehmigung zu bekommen und was zu tun
ist wenn sie etwas finden
so soll das sein vater und in der mitte
und nummeriert wunderbar also alles
römische münzen erstes jahrhundert nach
christus vermutlich
bei vielen landet so was einfach in der
schrottkiste hier wird's richten nummer
mit 1 gemessen und mit dem un bericht
offen und perfekt viele sondengänger
kooperieren gern mit den archäologen
andere fühlen sich von ihnen unnötig
kontrolliert sie wollen abenteuer sowie
axel tief und kracht er betreibt ein
internetportal mit dem namen deutsche
sondengänger union eine
schutzgemeinschaft weil von archäologie
seite oft behauptet wird dass man eben
generell eine genehmigung braucht und
dass leute die eben diese genehmigung
nicht haben als raub triebe unterwegs
sind und das ist einfach falsch solche
pauschalen aussagen wie öfters wie ich
jetzt öfters hier im umfeld schon gehört
habe man darf eigentlich überall sondern
ohne restriktionen zu fürchten dass es
definitiv falsch die fronten sind
verhärtet denn es gibt die schwarzen
schafe einige sondengänger jagen zum
beispiel gezielt nach militaria waffen
bomben oder munition wie hier im
reichswald das ist nicht nur gefährlich
sondern auch verboten genauso wie die
nicht genehmigte suche auf
grabungsstätten das sind ganz gezielte
raubgräber mit mafiösen strukturen die
ganz gezielt solche grabhügel anfahren
und dort ganz gezielt raubgrabungen
machen um halt kommerziell das ganze zu
betreiben für die archäologen ist das
eine katastrophe und wenn es auf so
einem befund aus seinem grab wohl
knochen schnitzereien drin waren
totenbett lag wenn da die ganzen
kompletten gefäße und münzen weg sind ja
weil sie jemand vorher geklaut hat das
ist dann für uns ein riesen verlust
die archäologen wollen die sondengänger
weiter zur zusammenarbeit bekehren und
amateure zu partnern machen ihnen zeigen
wie wertvoll die schätze im boden für
die nachwelt sind